he is a man who is Hall of Fame worthy
that is for darn sure and he is one of
the best receivers to play the game and
he's a member of the greatest show on
turf that started turning around the
Rams fortunes in this series that the
49ers had dominated for many many a year
and speaking of dominated he will be
such in the Allyson change this week
when we take on Torrey big game home how
are you Tori Goodrich how you doing
brother I am doing fine
I miss you Tori what you've been up to
oh man the one I just finished working
out of the doctor Mitch he's kind of got
me like something like I can play again
yes all right
yeah man so what just finished working
out coaching high school football here
in North Carolina
varsity varsity receiver coach over at
Heritage High School JV opens a
coordinator over at Heritage High School
and having a good time with that so I'm
getting my football fixed as well as
continuing to talk it with you and all
those around the country so that's got
me going and and then I'm excited about
what's going on with the Rams man I'm
talking a little fantasy football with
Sirius X now as well as Sirius XM NFL
radio so yeah so what Robo I know that
what makes you excited about what's
going on with the Rams Tori you know I'm
excited about how jarred golf is
continuing to develop and obviously
there's still growing pains with him
particularly the interception there at
the end of fall survey he just took the
linebacker right to the throw and he
hadn't been doing that all games so that
was uncharacteristic but just that
entire last portion of that two minutes
of that game was weird I was a lot going
on McVeigh looking with checking with
the plays and the clock and it was it
was just it was just a it was just that
it was a different team that took the
field on that possession in the prior
possessions but I like girly you know
despite the two fumbles he's back active
he's jumping over people fighting for
extra yards and four touchdowns so
that's exciting
I like Cooper Cup the rookie
he's not gonna blow by anybody but he
can he understands football is a heck of
a football player very productive in
college as we all know and you're seeing
flashes as you say in terms of that with
the Rams early
well Josh Reynolds get more involved
will they extend the will they extend
the offense beyond the the hashes to the
outside numbers so looking forward to we
see some of that tonight versus the
49ers cost the 49ers a week in the
secondary no air agreed so there's some
opportunities for them to make some
plays in the passing game but I'm
excited about the run game that defense
has got to get better it's good to have
Donald back in the mix I think he'll
help tonight they should be pissed off
250 nine yards rich that home at home
and Aaron Donald's back on the football
field I should be embarrassed so I think
they'll control Carlos high who's
playing phenomenal he's look he looks
really good he's getting he's running a
rock he went into Seattle as we all saw
last week and did his thing no one's
done it in Seattle in like five years
he's done it twice hundred yards rushing
so that tells you how he's feeling in
running the football they got to slow
down and run and then we can create
turnovers on own defense with scores
like we did in week one like they did in
week one we got a chance of going to San
Francisco and winning and we don't like
San Francisco and they don't like us you
mentioned yeah right I mean it the
doctor made sure you'll see tonight
that's kind of highlighted how we were
tired of losing to the 49ers for like 17
Street no before we get let's I want to
mention that before we get it deeper
into the story hole at big game 81 on
Twitter joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show as soon as I'm done with
Marshall and Michael and mooch on
Thursday Night Football tonight with our
postgame show the timeline greatest show
on turf premieres right after we are
done with the Rams and 49ers game and it
you know Curt and Marshall love to give
the business to mooch that you you
arrived in 99 as well I mean Marshall
got acquired yeah if you arrived yeah
and and then Kurt Warner ascended what
was that 1999 season like from your
perspective Torrey
well it was so fast rich I was just a
rookie so I'm trying to get in where I
fit in and have an impact I was six
chapter six overall so there was
expectations so in having marshal and
Adam chairman Tim Berman who we acquired
from Green Bay was a pro ray Agnew Ricky
Proehl Isaac list goes on marshal
Orlando a player that were pros you know
I was able to I was able to learn early
along with coach shovel coach honors
everyone really I was able to learn
quickly how to how to carry myself and
then what the expectations were and then
and how to go about getting it and Isaac
was fantastic in practice practice and
Ricky was God's trained hard worked hard
study hard and then Mike was just he
just entrusted in us to go out and do
our thing and he put us in great
situations to succeed and we had guys at
every spot for his all fits we had guys
at every spot that played at a very very
high clip very very high level obviously
Hall of Fame guys so they have that have
that on your team and guys assess
motivated guys on selfish guys were all
about trying to win it and prove to the
country that this this BS about the RAM
stink is over that it was good it was a
good environment for a young guy like
myself into a pie and rich Cody it's
great environment real keys to come into
so what was it like when Kurt went down
what's your recollection of that I mean
when when Trent went down oh man I was
saving him because because trip in that
game against against the preseason game
against San Diego ladies and gentlemen
Trent Green was 11 for 11 the ball
didn't touch the ground and you hear you
hear people make mumbles about their
balls don't touch the ground in practice
our balls didn't touch the ground in
practice and it was like that it was
carrying over to the preseason so I'm
like oh my goodness this is unbelievable
and then to see him go down was I was
devastating because all that it took to
get Trent there and to put the put the
pieces that they felt like digging the
staff felt like they had in place and
then to see that happen at a very
critical critical position on this
and shirt head arm talent smarts sneaky
athletic tough Parramatta had charisma
and you see that now with him all radio
and TV TV it was tough to watch treant
go down I was we were all were pulling
for him seven-time Pro Bowl wide
receiver Torrey Holt here on the Rich
Eisen show I know it's not it's like
Fight Club you don't talk about it but
who's pounding the table for you in the
in that selectors room for the Pro
Football Hall of Fame
who's in there talking Torrey hole on
your behalf I don't know I I hope I hope
all of them are can identify one person
but I hope they all are I mean they all
watched me play and I try to play it at
a at a and at a pro level at all pro
level and and all that and I had great
competition around me time when I was
playing it was Isaac and Marvin and
Randy and tio all these guys Jimmy Smith
Roger Smith Keaney McCarty let's goes on
just just really good wide receivers and
to be able to maintain in my era you
know around top five I think it's
respectable so my work is done I was
able to go to st. Louis with a group of
guys and win a Super Bowl and him and
then charting and give that city hope
and a championship inspire my teammate
so for me you know my work is done rich
so it's up to the voters it's up to the
fans and thanks to all the fans that
supported me three years look I love
playing football
if that happens great but I still got a
key it's not gonna stop me from loving
the game teaching the game still
supporting the game had been around
again rich not at all okay and speaking
of loving the game we're loving taking
you on in fantasy football this week
it's not my it's not no we it's me and
my colleague Chris Brockman am i right
right now how confident are you to take
on vultures of the ether in this fantasy
contest this week Torrey help you know
what I'm excited about
I was wanting to who won and to over the
weekend so I got to bounce back and
rinse release wow you're really every
three leagues is it really that Olson
went down so that that hurts oh man he's
so productive
and reliable and he's an Iron Man he's
one of the NFL's Iron Men you picked up
Evan Engram you picked up Evan Engram
for that yeah oh god Evan Engram so he's
questionable so see how he does but he
is the Evan Engram speaking of
everything Evan Engram he's the right
now the the brightest spot for the
Giants so and I think they'll continue
to get him even more involved in the
offense from a Flex position from the
tight end spot I think they can also
line him up wide and put old L inside I
like to see he and Odell on the same
side that if he well I saw you benched
you benched Brandon Marshall I mean
before I let you go what do you think's
going on with him in that offense you
know I don't I don't know I think he
he's pressing look to me he's pressing
rich because it wasn't good in week one
he wanted more targets week too few more
targets drops and what what happens you
as you start to press and that's what it
looks like to me that I'm seeing it with
Brandon Marshall and and where is his
sweet spot for them is it you know is it
tanning in at the 15 and in is it 15 and
stop where is his sweet spot for for the
Giants working help them best
III don't know if he if he has that
vertical presence anymore so but with
his but his body size and he's shown the
ability to run routes he's got to find
other ways to continue to win
concentrate on the ball that was always
his not know you just been an
inconsistent ball drop ball it's a it's
not like this has happened before me
this is just happening Brenda Marshall
has dropped balls were you pressing and
drop balls is a bad thing
he just got to relax find a sweet sweet
spot for him catches balls and just make
a routine plate asking the poll question
before we let Tory hold go that's
sitting there on Rich Eisen show app
Apple App Store Google Play the link at
the top of our Twitter handle out Rich
Eisen show Chris yeah Torre which oh and
two teams should re lax 49ers Giants
Bengals
Saints what do you think
what do you know is give it give it to
me one more time 49ers Giants Bengals
Saints which one do you think should
relax the fanbase should relax the most
everything's gonna be good Oh none of
them should relax I mean it's neither
down or 1/3 no one can relax ok we'll
accept that as an answer I would say
good luck this weekend in our fantasy
league but I don't mean it all right
but everything else with you Torre miss
chat with you and I let's have you back
on
whenever you're whenever you want
absolutely man I appreciate all the best
and ten my guys Michael and beyond and
curved and everyone and all the guys my
best five I be my pleasure to do that
that's Torry Holt at big game 81 the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that video be sure
to download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches